THURSDAY JUNE SEVENTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS HEREBY
CALLED ORDER. PLEASE BE ADVISED
ON AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDINGS
BEING MADE OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS AS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ATTENDING THIS HEARING
WAS WERE MASK AT ALL TIMES AND
COMPLY WITH GUIDANCE ON
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. ATTENDEES
ALSO REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT
THIS HEARING. VIOLATION OF
THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT AN
INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY THERE CUNNINGHAM THEN IT
FOR. GIPSON HERE WE MAIENSCHEIN
MATH HERE RAMOS RUBIO HERE THE
ABUJA YOUR- WEBER. BILL CLARK
WE HAVE A- WE HAVE A CONCERN
AGENDA WILL MOVE SEVEN MOVE BY
MR MAT SECONDED BY GIBBS IT'S A
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL- HI
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM SENATE
FLOOR. GIVES HI GIPSON HIGHLY
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS. MATHIS IRAN RUBIO RUBIO
HIGH VEHICLE WELL YOU WHAT
HIGHWAY. WEBER HI. SINCE OKAY
MOTIONS PASSED AND I THINK
COLLEAGUES I BELIEVE OF THE
COMMITTEE OPEN HERE FOR FREE
MASS A PAUL. THANK YOU CONCERT.
THIS PREVIOUS SUMMER RULES
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.